Rheinsberg هي واحدة من أفضل
مدن العصور الوسطى التي تم الحفاظ عليها في ألمانيا ، فهي موطن
لواحد من
أقدم مطاعم الجسور وأقدم
المصانع في البلاد ، وقد حصلنا على جائزة من
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
كمصنع للمستقبل ، هذا المركز التاريخي للتكنولوجيا الفائقة في هذه المدن التاريخية
هو واحد  من الخطط الأكثر تقدمًا اليوم
وهي في طليعة
الصناعة 4.0 منذ أكثر من مائة عام ، غيّر
رجل صناعي أمريكي إلى الأبد
طريقة عمل العالم حرفيًا ، قطع هنري فورد
الوقت اللازم لبناء السيارات إلى
النصف مع أول خط تجميع متحرك في الصناعة في
عام 1913 و
لقد تطورت الطريقة التي نصنع بها الأشياء منذ
أن الجيل التالي من التصنيع
لن يحدث فقط في أرض المصنع ،
بل سيحدث أيضًا على أجهزة
الكمبيوتر وفي السحابة ، يعد المصنع
الذكي طريقة ذكية لاستخدام التقنيات الجديدة
والأفكار الجديدة للحصول على  الابتكارات في المستوى التالي
غالبًا ما تكون المصانع الذكية عبارة عن
منشآت متصلة بالكامل حيث
يسخر الموظفون إمدادًا لا نهائيًا من البيانات
لتبسيط الإنتاج  يمكن أن تضيف هذه المصانع
ما لا يقل عن 1.5 تريليون دولار إلى
الاقتصاد العالمي في السنوات الثلاث المقبلة
وذلك لأن التقارب بين
العوالم المادية والرقمية له تطبيقات لا حصر لها
ولا أعتقد أنني
ذكي بما يكفي لإعطائك
نظرة عامة كاملة عن كل  التكنولوجيا التي نستخدمها
هنا في مصنع به أكثر من 3000
آلة متصلة
، فلا عجب أن فرانك يجد صعوبة في
تذكر كل ابتكار
، حيث تربط منصة إنترنت الأشياء المخصصة
هذه الأدوات بالمواد التي
تتلقى ملصقات مطبوعة بالليزر مما
يسمح بتحليل المعلومات وتتبعها في كل مرة.
خطوة على الطريق الآن يمكننا دمج البيانات
ما كانت الرطوبة وما هي
درجة الحرارة وما هو تدفق
تكلفة الخط هل هناك
أي اتصال يشرح سبب وجود مشكلة
إذا فهمنا هذه الواجهات
ثم يمكننا منع حدوث ذلك
الحصول على الصيانة التنبؤية في المستقبل هي
مجرد طريقة واحدة يستفيد بها الموظفون من
فرق خطوط تجميع الاتصال وهي
الساعات الذكية و glo  تساعد
هذه التقنيات في تخصيص السيارات بشكل أسرع والمركبات المستقلة على تبسيط اللوجيستيات من خلال تقديم أجزاء
سمحت لشركة BMW بتقليص الوقت اللازم
لنشر تطبيقات جديدة بنسبة 80٪
وتقليل مشكلات الجودة بنسبة 5٪ كما أنها
وضعت المصنع
في قائمة المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي.  معظم
المصانع المتقدمة تقنيًا في يناير 2019 من بين
أكثر من ألف متنافس في
جميع أنحاء العالم تم اختيار سبعة منهم فقط على
الرغم من الضجة حول إمكانات
التكنولوجيا الجديدة يقول فرانك إن هناك
موردًا واحدًا يتفوق دائمًا على
المصنع الذكي مدفوعًا بأشخاص أذكياء
يغيرون العمليات التقليدية دائمًا ما يمثل
تحديًا  الطريقة الوحيدة للقيام بذلك هي
أن تأخذ الناس معك